this deadly fungus known as cordyceps
has the ability to take out entire
species it's likely that the fungus
would attack your body as any other
parasite might
when you first become infected you'll
begin to feel some symptoms you've
probably felt before a fever abdominal
pain weakness and vomiting are all
possible consequences
you might also notice yourself getting
depressed as the cordyceps could affect
your dopamine levels
some of these effects might be familiar
but what isn't is how the fungus would
spread through your body
as time goes on the fungus would start
to take over your nervous system
since you're a lot bigger than something
like an insect it would take months for
the cordyceps to take full control of
you